hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk all about Lyanna Stark
you know a really big character in the
context of A Song of Ice and Fire
but someone we might not ever actually
get to meet the comments by Littlefinger
and sir Barristan Selmy in Episode four
it you know set the internet on fire
with R + L equals J confirmations
technically they did not confirm
anything about lyanna stark's maybe
maybe not son so what I'm gonna do is a
history for her character and then
explain the context for the prophecy
that everyone is talking about the one
that Rhaegar was obsessed with the
prince who was promised so just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far most of this
history is taken from anecdotal comments
based on things that characters have
said in story that we've already covered
the part of Lyanna Stark will be played
by Lily Collins in snow white attire I
know people always ask me whenever I use
other pictures for characters that we
haven't seen on the show Lyanna stark
was the sister of Brandon Stark and Ned
Stark Brandon Stark was the oldest
brother Ned Stark was in the middle
Lyanna Stark was the youngest she was
like the Aria of their family during
season 1 of the show Aria was even told
that she looked like her aunt Lyanna she
shares a lot of personality traits with
her but they're not like carbon copies
of each other
Arya Stark is it like the reincarnation
of Liana george RR martin is just famous
for repeating metaphors over time so a
lot of events situations characters and
present-day resemble things that happen
in the past that he's talked about but
that doesn't mean that they'll play out
the exact same way he's just a
self-described history nut and a lot of
times in real world history it seems
like events are repeating themselves as
described by Ned Liana was wolf blooded
very tomboyish very hot-blooded she said
to really have enjoyed using swords
although their father wouldn't allow her
to walk around carrying a sword but she
was very skilled on a horse so by all
accounts she was capable of taking care
of herself very strong-willed
independent and capable of defending
herself she was no flowery Maiden
speaking of which I know you know
Littlefinger made this comment about the
crown of blue roses at the attorney of
Harrenhal last week it's just that Leon
is described as being very fond of the
blue roses that grew at Winterfell bran
stark on the show right now actually
does get a picture like an actual look
at Lyanna stark he sees a girl that
looks like Arya we did a Maggy the Frog
fly
so it's possible that we could get a
Lyanna stark flashback but there's no
guarantee in bran stark isn't even part
of season five so until they say
otherwise you know most of what we learn
about her is gonna be when characters
talk to other characters about her in a
historical context I actually think
that's a really good way to do it it's
just a little more creative way to
convey history to do exposition so
moving along into the really important
moments that we've heard about on the
show the attorney of Harrenhal right
before that was when she had been
promised to Robert Baratheon when that
happened she said to have told Ned that
she had some misgivings about Robert you
know just because he was such a
man-whore
that's important for context in the
Lyanna Stark was not in love with Robert
Baratheon as is true of most political
marriages so then we moved to the
tourney of Harrenhal the show might not
ever explain it or they might tell it in
an offhanded story but in addition to
the Rhaegar crown of blue roses moment
that Littlefinger talked about there was
another big thing that happened at the
tournament she was a good friend of
Howland Reed one of the crown augment
you know Jojen read this character here
his father he was very young he was
being bullied by three other Squires
from three larger houses later in the
tournament a knight wearing the sigil of
a laughing tree unhorsed all three of
the Squires that had been bullying Hal
and Reed the identity of the night was a
huge mystery there's a lot of theories
that that night was Howland Reed himself
getting revenge on those Squires that
were making fun of him but there's also
a theory that the mystery Knight was
Lyanna stark after he won the last bout
the knight ran off into the woods took
off his armor and then ran off
Rhaegar Targaryen was ordered to go find
out who the knight was but he only found
the shield with the Laughing tree on it
also during that tournament
Rhaegar is said to have played such a
beautiful song that it made Lyanna stark
weep so everybody loses their when
Rhaegar gives the prize to Lyanna stark
a short time after the tournament is
when he is said to have kidnapped her
and run off so there's a lot of
anecdotal evidence to those two
characters having something of a
connection with each other whether it's
love or mutual interest or something
else remains to be seen so here is where
we get to the prophecy that Rhaegar is
said to be obsessed with the prince who
was promised the best theory is is that
it wasn't so much that he was in love
with Lyanna stark he might have just
thought that she was the crucial part of
the fulfillment of the prophecy
see we actually saw a version of this
prophecy but it was only in the books we
didn't see it on the show Daenerys has a
bunch of visions in the house of the
undying they just they cut that way down
to the show this is where it gets a
little confusing because there's a lot
of conflicting stories about who might
be the prince who is promised you know a
lot of people also think that Daenerys
might be and so we you know princess who
was promised in that case in Daenerys
his vision in the house of the undying
she sees Rhaegar saying this is the
prince who was promised and it's
seemingly Aegon the baby that was
supposed to have gotten its head dashed
against the wall by the mountain the
problem with visions is that they're
open to interpretation and sometimes
visions that you get can be of alternate
timelines like you know had things gone
differently these things might have gone
this way so don't ever take visions in
the literal context sidenote there's
also a lot of theories that the prince
who is promised is also the azure a high
character as told by Melisandre it's
just two different ways of interpreting
a very old prophecy you know Melisandre
comes from the faith of the red God
they're going to have a different
interpretation about the fulfillment of
the prophecy than say someone from
Westeros who's part of the faith of the
seven when Rhaegar took Liana though he
took her to the tower of joy that just
like on the northern edge of Dorne
I know a lot of people were hoping we
would see it when Jaime and Bronn went
to Dorne there's no promise of that but
you know we might get an easter egg like
someone might casually mentioned
something about that we don't know the
whole reason why Rhaegar took Lyanna
stark Viserys Targaryen actually told
Daenerys that Rhaegar was unhappy in his
marriage to Elia of Dorne so it's
possible that he was just infatuated
with Liana but he is someone who spent
his entire life dedicated to the
prophecy as a child he actually decided
to become a warrior after reading the
prophecy so I do think that he felt like
Lyanna stark was part of the prophecy
when she was first taken Brandon stark
found out about it and went to the red
keep to get help from Aerys Targaryen to
ask him to deal with it
Aerys had Brandon and his companions
other you know highborn Nobles arrested
for treason he accused them of plotting
murder
they chose trial by combat and Aerys
chose fire as his champion this is where
things really heat up with Robert's
rebellion this is the primary reason it
started not because Lyanna stark was
taken starting a rebellion requires
massive support one weight
that is to kill the warden of the north
his oldest son and several highborn
Nobles
so John Aaron joined forces with the
north just like Littlefinger said he
would do as Roose Bolton now and they
declared war on the Targaryen z'
so the rebellion didn't happen overnight
during that Rhaegar had to leave for
battle at the Trident that's where
Robert killed him he is said to have
died whispering Liana's name and when
Ned finally found Liana at the Tower of
joy she was said to be covered in blood
and whisper to Ned promised me the
serious is that Ned found her after just
having a baby and she said promise me
you'll take care of him and that's what
she meant one of the few people that's
still alive in the context of this show
that was at the Tower of joy is Howland
Reed we haven't seen him but you know
unless confirmed otherwise he's still
presumed to be alive running around
somewhere so if you're ever looking for
like absolute confirmation on who lyanna
stark's child was or whether or not she
actually had a child there's still
someone the show can trot out to do that
I don't expect it to go down that way
you know if we ever learn who Jon Snow's
mother is it'll probably be in somewhat
more vague terms just more of what we
saw last week you know characters
telling stories that seem to imply a
certain outcome I just think it's a lot
more fun that way most of the best
theories I've seen about Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna stark at the Tower
of joy take a more practical approach to
the characters he took her more because
of the prophecy then than because of
love it wasn't so much an active
aggression as an act of utility this
must happen this must come to pass so
that we can fulfill the prophecy so this
show does anything is just gonna be
dropping hints what I'm really hoping
they do is that we see Jon Snow and more
white Walker scenes so we can see
whether or not the show is going to back
him into season six and seven anybody is
fair game to be killed off but it's easy
to see when the show is backing a
certain character as one of the pillars
of the story like we want you to feel a
certain way about this character like
Stannis for instance he seemed like an
for the first couple of seasons
but now the show wants you to think of
him as a good character so the rest of
the episodes this season will give you
an idea of how the show wants you to
think of Jon Snow lately it has been
that he has very special power that
Melisandre wants him to explore all the
stars are confirmed wharves so she could
just be talking about that and even if
he really is Ned's bastard and not
Liana's son he would still be half Noble
I mean he would still have the same kind
of power in his blood that Gendry had
so there's a number of interpretations
but you guys let me know you know do you
think that Jon Snow is the son of Lyanna
stark and rhaegar targaryen
and do you think that the show is going
to back him as like one of the most
important characters we know along with
Daenerys until like season six and seven
in related news episode five tonight be
sure to subscribe to get that I'm gonna
be doing a new round of the giveaway I
will be giving away the signed copies of
feast for crows and dance with Dragons
they're both hardback signed by george
RR martin so just watch my episode 5
video you guys will see in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click here for
my episode 5 video I'll add the
annotation after I post the video
tonight and you can click here to learn
all about the history of Winterfell
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight